[Musique]
c'est une histoire qui finit bien le
récit d'une opération qui a permis
d'évacuer d'un pays plongé dans le chaos
près d'un millier de ressortissants dont
700 étrangers de 80 nationalités
différentes pour la raconter nous avons
rencontré celles et ceux qui ont eu un
rôle clé dans ce sauvetage document
inédit dans lequel ils reviennent sur
ces 15 jours où l'audace a S répondre à
[Musique]
l'urgence en avril 2023 des
affrontements éclatent au Soudan entre
les forces armées soudanaises et les
paramilitair des forces de soutien
rapide après deux guerres civiles le
trisème plus grand pays africain est une
nouvelle fois fragilisé rapidement la
capitale carartou est coupée de tout le
début d'une longue angoisse quand la
guerre a commencé c'était un samedi
matin donc j'étais à la Résidence
puisque c'était un jour de weekend et il
était 9h20 du matin un peu près quand je
reçois un appel de l'un de mes collègues
de l'ambassade puis il me dit B ça y est
la guerre vient de commencer madame
l'ambassadeur je suis dit quoi alors
j'en croyais pas mes oreilles le samedi
soir donc le le général bité qui
commande les forces françaises
stationnées à Djibouti les FFDj convoque
l'ensemble de ces grandes subordonnées
pour faire un point de situation euh une
appréciation de situation sur ce qui est
en train de se passer au Soudan
voilà on y apprend que des combats
violents font rage depuis le le début de
la journée dans carartou que nos
ressortissant voilà qu'on estime à peu
près à 250 300 se retrouve au milieu de
ces
combats tout ce qu'on savait c'était que
les RSF les rapid support forces du
général HTI le vice-président soudanais
et les forces armées souanaises se
tiraent dessus on avait constaté
quelques jours avant une intensification
des tensions entre les deux hommes mais
de là à s'imaginer que ce ton qui
montait entre les deux aller déboucher
sur des fusillades et des bombardements
dès le premier jour comme ça le samedi
15 avril non moi j'étais l'astreinte
donc au au CPCO assez calme he le samedi
il y a quand même peu de monde moins de
monde en tout cas et donc là on a on a
une première alerte avec des combats qui
commencent on met en œuvre toute la
chaîne de décision et de de de
planification telle qu'elle est telle
qu'elle est conçue donc on éclenche cell
de crise quasiment dans la foulée dès le
dimanche matin et puis bien sûr on prend
on prend contact avec le théâtre et on
envoie nos nos éléments de liaison vers
le le le meae ministère des Affaires
étrangères et de l'Europe donc au sein
du CDCS pour justement
prendre réaliser pardon les premières
réunions de concertation avec eux au
centre de crise nous sommes en
permanence d'astreinte donc on a une
équipe de 13 agents qui est d'astreint
toutes les semaines et qui doit être en
capacité d'activer une cellule de crise
en 1 heure donc c'est ce qu'on fait le
le 17 avril et à ce moment-là nous
rejoignent d'autres agents très
vite l'ouverture d'une cellule de crise
ça veut dire très concrètement qu'on
commence à contacter l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens via mail via SMS via
messagerie instantanée pour leur
demander de nous dire s'ils sont bien au
soudant s'ils vont bien combien ils sont
s'ils ont des stocks des vivres de l'eau
pour qu'on puisse nous avoir une
cartographie assez précise de combien de
ressortissants on a effectivement sur
place et de combien on va avoir à en
évacuer j'étais responsable de l'échelon
national d'urgence du
cpa1 qui comprend deux groupes action
plus des éléments de renfort et qui sont
d' alerte à 6h et avec une composante
contre terrorisme et Libération d'otage
donc mardi matin je suis tranquillement
en train de me réveiller vers 10h euh vu
que je vais passer la nuit à travailler
et je reçois un coup de téléphone de mon
escadron qui me dit
tu ne vas peut-être pas faire l'exercice
mais partir sur une alerte je demande
quelques précisions sur la température à
prévoir histoire de faire une valise en
conséquence je sais juste que on nous
demande à quelle heure au plus tôt on
peut décoller euh en réfléchissons un
peu nous on annonce qu'à 17h heure
locale France on peut partir d'Orléan
pour la destination qu'on nous donnera
donc là on me dit euh soit Djibouti soit
kartou soit en direct soit en passant
par l'Orient pour récupérer les
commandos marines du COS je reçois un
coup de téléphone vers 20h en me disant
est-ce que éventuellement j'étais
disponible pour partir en mission
potentiellement le soir même parce que
une action se déclenchait sans qu'on ait
plus de précision donc c'était au cas où
une demi-heure après le téléphone
ressonne en disant bon ben il y a une
mission qui se déclenche avec le module
de chirurgie vitale on apprend qu'on va
qu'on ne va pas rejoindre la zone
d'action directement mais qu'on va
générer l'ensemble de la force sur
Djibouti et que ça nous servira de de
base arrière pour effectuer notre
opération on a projeté euh donc euh dans
les T premiers jours des premiers
éléments de renfort à la fois au au sein
du du de l'état-major donc de Djibouti
et puis un C de capacité particulière
capacité de d'avion de transport ainsi
que de d' détachement du comment des
opérations spéciales voilà si jamais il
fallait que l'on réalise une opération
de d'extraction de force de nos
ressortissants avec un renfort notamment
du du gignn également pour la protection
de de de l'ambassaderice et de
l'ambassade
donc sont partis depuis la base aérienne
de d'orlean Brissy trois avions à 400 m
et un avion Hercule qui se sont étalés
pour ce qui est pour ce qui est des
départs sur une période de 48 à
72h d'ailleurs le général boit annonce
que le le 18 les forces françaises
station à Djibouti sont en opération à
ce momentl là on sait pas exactement
quel mode d'action va être choisi est-ce
qu'on va y aller par les airs est-ce
qu'on va y aller par la mer est-ce qu'on
va y aller par la route voilà donc on
prépare on prépare tous les cas de
figure et donc on a franchi suè le 18
avril et le 19 avril donc on est dans le
Golf de Suise en sortie du canal là le
la frégate reçoit le la directive de
raller rapidement les approches de des
côtes souanaises pour dans un premier
temps effectuer du recueil de
renseignement et puis se tenir paré à
toute éventualité
au niveau opératif et et tactique
évidemment on a on a plein d'options qui
sont envisagées et qui des fois
malheureusement c'entrechoque avec la
réalité stratégique voilà il y a des
partenaires il y a des enjeux il y a des
enjeux de territoire de de souveraineté
des il y a il y a des Lutes d'influence
qui qui des fois peuvent mettre à mal la
planification c'est c'est le jeu des
opérations c'est donc le président de la
République qui décide de déclencher
l'évacuation sur la base des
informations euh que nous lui faisons
remonter via euh nos ministres
respectifs euh et le chef d'état-major
des armées ainsi que le chef
d'état-major particulier un volet aérien
est privilégié euh parce que la ville de
Cartou est à 800 km des côtes et donc il
est évident qu'il est plus aisé d'aller
euh évacuer les personnes par voie
aérienne euh malgré tout euh euh côté
maritime la laorine est euh est donc
prépositionné euh et se tient paré au
cas où on étudié au niveau géographique
toutes les options qu' pvent y avoir de
de de de
d'aéroport autre que celui de kartou
puisque très rapidement c'est un
aéroport qui a une piste qui va faire à
peu près 2500 m puis au fur à mesure des
combat la voie se réduire à 1800 1200 et
puis devenir complètement inopérationnel
puisque des obus qui sont en permanence
dessus on a trouvé assez rapidement au
au nord nord-ouest de kartou une base
aérienne donc de l'armée de l'armée
souanaise le COS est impliqué parce que
les ressortissants ne seront pas
rassemblés directement sur l'aéroport
mais qu'il va va falloir aller les
chercher en ville à différents points de
rassemblement je serai probablement
l'avion qui va
ouvrir le
terrain pour être sûr de le sécuriser
avec des éléments du COS avant que
d'autres avions fassent une noria de de
résevac et le reste de la partie résevac
sera réellement géré par la partie
conventionnelle que ce soit les avions
ou l'armé de terre qui est plus
spécialisé dans le tri et le
rassemblement de de tous les
ressortissants
donc je vais partir avec un détachement
d'environ 150 personnes un petit PC
tactique pour conduire l'opération à mes
côtés je vais avoir des Mar soins de la
première compagnie euh voilà avec leur
capitaine à leur tête qui vont être en
charge principalement de la partie
sécurisation je vais avoir un
détachement du groupement de soutien des
des forces françaises stational Djibouti
dont dont la mission va être
véritablement l'accueil des
ressortissants leur filtrage
l'organisation euh un peu administratif
de leur de leur évacuation avec le
renfort de de deux personnes du centre
de crise et de soutien du du qué d'orcé
voilà sur la partie interministérielle
et gestion gestion des ressortissants je
vais avoir également une équipe
d'aviatrices et d'aviateurs de la base
aérienne 188 de Djibouti en charge de la
coordination aérienne et en charge de
toute la partie escale et gestion
logistique parking des avions euh bien
évidemment un gros détachement santé
voilà y compris un module de chirurgie
vitale une de le premières cinte c'était
notamment que d'avoir des des
ressortissants qui soient isolés bloqués
chez eux qui soit tué ou blessé ça été
une une crainte permanente ça plus le
fait d'avoir un avion abattu en l'air
par exemple opposé ou au décollage les
les les risques ont été très importants
euh je pense à la au cour bord qui a
posé le prier
C30 en pleine nuit sur un terrain dont
on ne savait absolument pas comment on
serait accueilli ça a été vraiment des
risques qui ont été qui été très
important 40 50 km avant d'approcher de
l'aéroport on se prépare pour la phase
de descente donc on commence à
réellement observer le le sol avec des
des conflits qui sont finalement
beaucoup plus denses que ce à quoi on
s'attendait on était réellement sur une
guerre civile avec deux forces en
présence qui qui combattait jour et
nuit donc c'était assez impressionnant
mais comme c'était très silencieux on
voyait le la guerre sans l'entendre on
s'est ensuite
donc rapproché de l'aéroport et là pour
la première fois j'ai eu un contrôleur
puisque céit un contrôleur militaire qui
était très surpris d'avoir quelqu'un en
fréquence euh il avait été informé mais
je pense qu'il était convaincu qu'on
viendrai pas et donc c'est ça remarque à
juste été on m'a demandé de vous
autoriser à atterrir je vous le
déconseille plus personne ne pose c'est
dangereux et donc à partir de ce
moment-là on on est passé en autonomie
donc on a sorti notre caméra et on a
survolé pendant 15 à 30 minutes
l'aéroport le but était un d'évaluer si
euh il y avait une menace donc d'essayer
de voir les groupes armés qu'il y avait
si on était encore sur de la force du du
pays ou sur la force rebelle mais aussi
principalement de vérifier l'état de la
piste relativement vite en 15 20 minutes
on confirme que la piste est accessible
que le parking est accessible et que
nous sommes attendu un certain nombre de
pickup le long de la piste sont
clairement en train d'attendre notre
[Musique]
atterrissage moi je suis dans le 4e
avion il y a quatre avions qui posent
qui posent à ce moment-là euh et au
moment en fait où on sort de l'avion
donc nuit totale optique de nuit sur les
yeux parce que voilà toutes les lumières
sont éteintes bien évidemment pour des
des questions de de sécurité et moi à ce
moment-là euh je vais prendre contact
évidemment avec les les commandos qui
sont arrivés en premier établir une
première appréciation de situation
notamment sur le le volet sécurisation
qui va être mon principal sujet est-ce
que l'aérodrome est sécurisé voilà et
mon deuxème sujet ça va être de prendre
contact avec les autorités souanaises
qui a les marins avec le GN qui avait le
qui avait on va dire le lead sur la
partie convoi premier convoi motorisé
donc eux ils se mettent en ordre de de
bataille ils préparent leur itinéraire
on avait trois points de regroupement
qui ont été connus que dans les
dernières heures évidemment donc la
résidence où j'étais du l'autre côté du
Nil là j'avais déjà quelques Français
qui étaient là l'ambassade qui a
accueilli le plus gros du contingent dès
le début y compris les agents avec leurs
familles leurs enfants et petit à petit
il y a eu des gens qui sont venus petit
à petit petit à petit tout au long de la
semaine il y a eu un trè point de
regroupement également qui avait été
identifié grâce à une française qui
avait une très grande villa pendant
encore quelques heures on me demande de
garder la capacité de redécoller avec le
C130 du Poitou si jamais les convois ne
passent pas je vais sauter sur Caron
donc ça dure encore pendant 2h et
ensuite on arrive à savoir que la
situation pourrait nous permettre à
l'aube ou en fin de nuit d'envoyer le
premier convoi des marins et du GGN donc
je range mes parachutes le le le poit
tout redécolle et on reste entre command
sur la sur la plateforme et nous en fait
toute cette phase d'attente on va
préparer notre dispositif
d'accueil moi je vais continuer à gérer
la partie la partie
souanaise également à planifier
l'ensemble des vols puisque dès le
lendemain on a aussi des avions euh
voilà d'autres nations qui vont arriver
et l'idée c'est que dès le moment où les
ressortissants arrivent sur l'aéroport
on puisse faire un voilà un tri un un
comptage entre guillemets des des
ressortissants très rapides et qui ait
un avion qui soit juste là qui puisse
embarquer directement et partir partir
sur dbouti on commence à monter notre
module de chirurgie vitale sur le tarmac
de l'aéroport parce que ce qu'il faut
c'est que nous on soit certes pas trop
loin des des combats mais aussi proche
de d'une structure d'évacuation
notamment là les avions parce que on ne
peut pas garder un malade et un blessé
éternellement il faisait extrêmement
chaud puisquil faisait plus de 40°gr
dehors donc sous la tente on pouvait
rajouter 10 ou 15 degrés de
plus qui m'a beaucoup frappé quand j'ai
été exfiltré c'était que sur 30 km à peu
près donc normalement c'est un trajet
qui se fait en voiture pendant 25 30
minutes 40 minutes pas plus jusqu'à la
base là on a mis presque 2h he à cause
des checkpoints et donc vous avez des
gens des des gens armés bien sûr des
combattants armés des soldats des enfin
lourdement
armés vous vous sentez bien qu'il y a
une frénésie une sorte de
[Musique]
nervosité une fois que l'ambassadrice
euh de France est récupéré et ramené sur
la sur la plateforme euh je prends la
tête d'un d'un convoi euh d'un convoi
motorisé et ma mission c'est de rallier
l'ambassade l'ambassade française donc
là c'est le deuxième convoi qui qui
partira de de de la plateforme on
narrive pas à avoir d'escorte on lance
quand même le convoi on est 32 on est h
véhicules et malgré tout on est on est
la cible à chaque checkpoint de
des volontés des des saut d'humeur de
jeunes de moins jeunes qui sont dans un
état de ner vraiment très avancé et on
voit vraiment se fait braquer à tous les
checkpoint je rends compte à ma
hiérarchie que je franchis le N et que
la prochaine étape pour moi c'est
l'ambassade française en parallèle j'ai
les copains de la Marine qui qui ont
choisi un autre itinéraire et qui sont
en train d'arriver qui sont déjà arrivés
à
l'ambassade commen l'extraction d'une
partie des des ressortissants et les
premiers convoi entre l'ambassade
française et euh la plateforme qui est
au nord et eux reçoivent aussi des des
tirs euh sur leur sur leur trajet retour
donc ils ne peuvent pas m'aider ils sont
en train de gérer des bus des volumes
impressionnants de français et en fait
je suis tout seul et donc
euh donc là on s'engage sur le pont donc
arrivé à la moitié euh bah là on sait
prendre la partie
euh on a des voilà il y a a des gerbes
de de de de balle qui qui qui ricolent
sur sur le bitum euh assez rapidement
mon véhicule prend prend un tir sur le
capot et quand on redescend de de ce
pont et qu'on prend on contourne le
l'aérodrome de l'aéroport de
international de carartou donc là on est
à 3 ou 4 km de de l'ambassade donc là je
fais accélérer franchement le convoi on
roule à 70 80 km/h on essaie de sortir
pour appliquer des feux mais franchement
ça va vite et là
j'entends 5 10 secondes après j'entends
un blessé un blessé ben j'envoie trois
véhicules directement sur le sur le
blessé et moi je me je me tiens à 50 m
pour essayer d'avoir une une
appréciation correcte de de de de ce qui
est en train de se jouer là là il y a
des mecs qui veulent nous tuer vraiment
quoi donc on a cette info là qu'il y a
un militaire blessé on sait que c'est
par balle et potentiellement au niveau
du thorax et de l'abdomène donc on sait
que c'est d'emblé une blessure grave et
qu'on s'attend déjà nous à devoir le
prendre en charge au bloc opératoire
donc à partir de ce moment-là on met
tout en place pour pouvoir l'accueillir
le plus rapidement possible on sait ce
qu'on a à faire ça s'organise très très
rapidement mon adjoint a déjà récupéré
le médecin et l'infirmier ils sont déjà
en train de travailler sur le sur le
blessé à la stabilisation là quand on a
un peu de temps bah tous les gens qui
sont qualifiés dans le domaine médical
ben ils vont ils vont se se se se rendre
disponible auprès du du binôme santé les
autres essayent d' de prendre des
initiatives c'està-dire de de regarder
avec quel véhicule on va pouvoir
repartir quel véhicule est encore en
état de repartir quand on l'a récupéré
il était stabilisé par l'équipe sur
place et après ce premier check on
voyait qu'il y avait potentiellement pas
d'atteinte au niveau thoracique mais au
niveau abdominal qui avait un risque
d'atteinte abdominale qu'on voyait pas
bien que l'échographie était pas très
concluante donc là on a décidé du coup
de de lui faire une chirurgie abdominale
pour aller arrêter le saignement à 10
minutes du posé je me souviens qu'on a
qu'on a reçu un appel à ce moment-là euh
qui a un petit peu compliqué le la
mission puisqu'il s'agissait cette
fois-ci non pas de seulement de
d'évacuer des ressortissants mais on
nous a parlé d'un d'un blessé au combat
de en stade A comme c'est un militaire
nous on doit tout faire pour qu'il
puisse garder ses
aptitudes ultérieures donc voilà donc il
faut qu'on pas trop qu'on en fasse mais
il faut qu'on on arrive à faire de à de
quoi traiter ses lésions notamment
hémorragiques sachant que en aval il
sera évacué rapidement vers des
structures chirurgical que soit Djibouti
et plus tard vers la métropole je dirais
pas que ça rajoute un un stress mais à
ce moment-là euh à ce moment-là pourra
être tout à fait honnête s'il y a il a
un regain de motivation et de de
concentration pour pour pour aller au
bout il va falloir sortir des
ressortissants qui sont euh qui sont
pour beaucoup complètement désespérés et
potentiellement sauver la vie d'un d'un
frère d'arme finalement on n' pas eu
attendre beaucoup de temps après la
chirurgie puisque l'avion s'est posé une
quinzaine vingtaine de minutes après
après qu'on ait fini l'opération c'est
sûr que si le module avait pas été mis
sur place l'intervention aurait été
aurait été trop tardive on sait que
c'était le bon choix et et puis et puis
pour le coup c'est ça révélé extrêmement
utile puisque c'est ce qui a permis de
sauver la vie dere camarade qui avit été
blessé sur le tarmac une fois qu'on a
contrôlé nos nos armes qu'on a soufflé
un coup qu'on a mangé qu'on a débriefé
en fait il y a une mission qui nous
attend c'est c'est c'est les
ressortissants il y a on est venu pour
ça en fait donc on se remobilise on va
voir les opérateurs on leur demande
comment ça va et là on comprend que
rapidement il y a un
convoi on va dire un peu plus lourd qui
qui qui va recevoir la mission de
rejoindre de rejoindre l'ambassade et là
ce coupci on va
réussir on est arrivé dans la nuit du
samedi au dimanche et on va repartir
dans la nuit du lundi au mardi
euh avec l'ensemble du détachement et je
vais malgré tout laisser sur place mon
chef opération avec une toute petite
équipe euh avec une mission particulière
ça va être justement de faciliter euh la
coordination de de l'opération générale
d'évacuation qu'on va confier aux
partenaires allemands d'établir une
transition entre les Soudanais et les
Allemands avec voilà avec mon chef
opération également nous assurer qu'il y
ait pas de ressortissant français qui
arrive de manière un petit peu isolé ou
qui avait pas qui n'était pas forcément
dans le scope des autorités des
autorités consulaire a dans ces 48
heures 10 conv terrestes à peu près et
on on évacue un peu plus à peu près 600
ressortissants donc nos nos 200 français
tels qu'il était prévu et puis en fait
tous les les nos alliés européens et et
il y a plus de 80 nationalités qui sont
qui sont présenté donc un certain nombre
de d'autres nations qui se présentent et
que le MAE fait embarquer dans les
avions en direction de Djibouti je
connaissais Djibouti mais je n'avais
jamais été là bon c'est très
impressionnant naturellement une
profonde reconnaissance également aux
autorités giibousienne de nous permettre
d'avoir une base logistique aussi
importante j'ai été accueillie par ma
collègue ma collègue et amie d'Anna
pourcarescou elle m'a accueilli sur le
tarmac avec le général boité qui m'a
régulièrement tenu au courant qui qui a
été vraiment très très proche d'une très
grande
humanité on pourrait avoir cette image
et c'est certainement ce que ce qu'on
imagine ce qu'on souhaite assez
bizarrement avant la mission de se dire
que on va faire quelque chose pour
lequel on va être on va être
potentiellement
[Musique]
récompensé humainement parlant qu'on va
avoir des regards de gratitude et en
fait c'est pas du tout ça et c'est
encore plus fort et c'est simplement des
regards de de de relâchement
d'apaisement quand les gens descendent
de l'avion où on se rend compte que pour
eux c'est le calvaire est terminé mais
les militaires étaient vraiment très
calm très voilà chacun était à sa tâche
moi je vraiment je leur tire mon chapeau
hein parce que c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment quelque chose on sent les très
grands très grands professionnels et ils
savent gérer des gens qui sont peut-être
un petit peu fatigués psychologiquement
et cetera ils savent ils savent les
gérer également et il faut bien
imaginer voilà que certains arrivent
sans bagage voilà sans rien ils ont
juste eu le temps de prendre le strict
nécessaire non pas forcément de change
et à Djibouti bien évidemment l'ensemble
des voilà des militaires des des FFDj
vont
organiser leur accueil faciliter leur
départ vers vers la France ou leur pays
de de voilà mais il y a pas que les
militaires il y a également toutes nos
familles voilà qui elles qui elles aussi
sont euh bien évidemment sur place et va
y avoir un élan très naturel voilà de de
générosité
[Musique]
d'aide on va essayer au maximum de
permettre à nos ressortissants de de
sortir en sécurité et si on peut en
prendre d'autres on va le faire donc on
on a une obligation de moyen c'est une
obligation qui est la nôtre he c'est
vraiment la grandeur de la France de
faire ça si je puis le dire en mots
peut-être un peu grandiloquant mais qui
révèle vraiment la manière dont se font
les choses c'est-à-dire que le ministère
des armées le ministère des Affaires
étrangères nos autorités si on peut le
faire on va le faire donc là il se
trouve qu'il y avait effectivement la
frégate La Lorine qui était mobilisable
le le Soudan est un pays où
effectivement il y avait depuis un
certain nombre d'années quasiment une
vingtaine d'années plus de plus d'escal
de bateaux français donc dans un premier
temps on a on a cherché ch à récupérer
des cartes à jour pour naviguer en
sécurité jusqu'à
jusqu'auok ensuite on a envoyer une
reconnaissance nautique pour pour
vérifier alors deux aspects un aspect
sécuritaire évaluer évaluer la situation
sécuritaire du port et et de ses
approches voir si on pouvait si on
pouvait s'accoster sans sans
être sans sans subir une attaque et
deuxième aspect également vérifier euh
la qualité du quai et et vérifier les
sondes c'est vérifier queil y a assz de
profondeur pour que le bateau puisse
accoster dans cette
zone nous avions proposé 400
places pour pour évacuer les personnes
sur un convoi de 1200 et donc le choix
qui a été fait par par les officiers de
sécurité des Nations unies était de nous
envoyer évidemment les personnes les
plus vulnérables les plus fragiles les
plus fatiguées embarquer une centaine
d'enfants c'est quelque chose d'assez
inédit quand on s'entraîne en général on
a toujours un ou deux enfants une ou
deux personnes âgées et là c'était le
cœur quasiment un/art de des personnes
embarquées étaient des enfants puis le
volume de personnes est également assez
inédit on avait pas d'expérience sur
frégate multimission c'est la première
fois que l'on procéde à une évacuation
avec ce type de de
bateau une fois qu'on nous avons
apparayer de de Port Soudan nous avons
fait route vers l'Arabie Saoudite donc
on traverse la mer Rouge c'est une
navigation qui dure 8 10h à vitesse
maximum nous allons appariller dans dans
la nuit vers 11h minuit pour arrivé le
lendemain matin à jeda en Arabie
Saoudite on va récupérer un autre convoi
terrestre de l'ONU qui essaie de sortir
pour le coup par l'ouest du pays qui est
bloqué dans la ville d'alfacher on était
donc cette fois-ci de à 400m un C130 du
Poitou avec une manœuvre d'infiltration
qui a été assez similaire à celle de à
celle de kartou euh avec donc un un C130
du Poitou qui pose qui pose en premier
qui qui nous donne le feu vert pour pour
intervenir 1 heure pour que le CPAL
prenne en compte tous les personnels de
l'ONU donc qui cette fois-ci devait
rejoindre l'aéroport en autonomie
c'était c'était un peu le contrat et une
fois que tous les personnels étaient
bien triés et pris en compte par le
CPA10 un A400M posé pour les récupérer
on parlait à ce moment-là d'une centaine
de de
passagers
[Musique]
c'est une grande satisfaction quand on
est fonctionnaire et qu'on travaille
pour l'état de voir ce que les agents et
les services peuvent faire quand ils
sont vraiment en symbiose et tous motivé
par le même objectif et on a vu toute
l'efficacité du travail qu'on fait au
quotidien avec les ambassades avec nos
homologues avec nos partenaires à
l'étranger pour se coordonner le vrai
point fort à cette manœuvre je pense que
ça a été
la situation de no forces prépositionner
le fait d'avoir sur place unétatmajor
opératif qui connaît la zone qui a
finalement des connexions et des liens
avec avec des acteurs sur place et qui a
une véritable capacité de commandement
en fait ça nous a fait gagner plusieurs
jours je retiens c'est mes hommes c'est
mes hommes qui ont pas forcément besoin
d'être commandé qui auraient pu se
passer de moi ce jour-là mais et qui ont
fait un travail incroyable ce que je
retiens c'est c'est ces sourirees à
l'aéroport et malgré tout une fois qu'on
a ouvert les portes du bus qu'on a
ouvert les portes de notre voiture on
leur souhaite bon vent et en fait on les
revoit
[Musique]
jamais